women in Florida the nation's third most
populous state will now only be able to
get abortions within the first six weeks
after conception a point at which many
women still don't even know they're
pregnant Florida now joins the ranks of
a dozen republican-led states that have
enacted near total bans on abortion in
the 10 months since the Supreme Court
undid nearly 50 years of federal
protections and GOP lawmakers aren't
stopping there in Texas Republicans are
pushing to block websites that provide
information about abortions just this
month Idaho made it a felony to help a
minor get an abortion out of state now
several democrat-led states are
stockpiling abortion medication the
latest front in this fight